[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين
عمليات الانقاذ في سوريا وتركيا متباعده
والجهود التركيه تتركز على اسكان المشردين
واعاده الاعمار
دخول المساعدات عبر معبر باب الهوى الى
شمال غرب سوريا مستمر والعدد الاجمالي يصل
الى 160 شاحنات
تعهدات جديده من الناتو لاوكرانيا بتقديم
اسلحه ثقيله والقتال حول مدينه باكموت
يستعر في ظل اصرار اوكراني في الدفاع عنه
والاتحاد الاوروبي يعلن عن حزمه عقوبات
عاشره ضد روسيا تشمل سبعه كيانات ايرانيه
تزود موسكو بالمسيرات
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه
باتت جهود الانقاذ في تركيا وسوريا
متباعده وقليله وتحولت الى مشاعر لاسكان
المشردين بفعل الزلزال
وفي وقت تحاول السلطات التركيه حث السكان
على العوده الى منازلهم التي ثبت انها
امنه يبقى الوضع في شمال غرب سوريا اكثر
تعقيدا
فالاسر منهكه تماما بفعل الحرب في الاساس
وهي تكافح وسط الركام للبحث عن مفقودين
قدر المرصد السوري عددهم بالف شخص
جيت ولا قوه الاضراب قدامي
قصص مؤثره خلفها زلزال تركيا وسوريا فهذه
المراه المسنه تشكو ماساتها وتامل ربما في
العثور على ناجين من ذويها ومثلها اخرون
فقدوا الابناء والاحبه
شهداء وطالعونا بس بنت واحده من تحت
الانقاض المشهد في سوريا المنقسمه مناطقها
المنكوبه بين سيطره النظام والمعارضه اصبح
الحديث فيها عن تلاشي امل العثور عنا جينا
جدد خاصه بعد اعلان المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان ان عدد المفقودين في سوريا يقدر
باكثر من 2000 شخص اغلبهم في جنديرس وقرى
مختلفه لم تصلها اصلا فرق الانقاذ
المرصد اضاف ايضا ان ما يجري حاليا في
المناطق المنكوبه هو رفع الانقاض وتحديد
مراكز لايواء الناجين مع توفير مساعدات
امميه ودوليه بدات تصل تباعا الى سوريا
في المقابل المشهد في تركيا مختلف بعض
الشيء وان كان متحركا في مدينه من اصل 10
ضربها الزلزال هما هاتاي وقهرمان مرعش
ومع استمرار عمليات البحث عن ناجينا جدد
في تركيا برزت قضيه المفقودين
لتمثل هاجسا مقلقا للسلطات وخوفا حقيقيا
لذوي المفقودين وتقول فرق الانقاذ ومنظمات
انسانيه ان كل من بقي تحت ركام زلزال
تركيا وسوريا يعتبر في عداد الموتى رغم
دخول عمليات البحث عن ناجين يومها العاشر
[تصفيق]
كما وشهد معبر باب الهوى تجمعا لعائلات
سوريه لاجئه في تركيا شرددها الزلزال
واظهرت الصور تكدس العائلات السوريه عند
المعبر للعوده الى سوريا
[موسيقى]
معي من مدينه كوفنتري في بريطانيا مدير
المرصده السوري لحقوق الانسان رامي عبد
الرحمن استازرامي اهلا وسهلا بك الى نشره
الخامسه بدايه اخر تحديث وصل قم لعدد
الضحايا سواء القتلى والجرحى وماذا عن
المفقودين
خصوصا وان يعني الحديث يعني يدور حول
ارقام مخيفه في اعداد المفقودين نعم نعم
مساء الخير هي ارقام مخيفه لان العدد يعني
كل دقائق او كل ساعه نكتشف بان هناك
المفقودين بالفعل قد فارقوا الحياه وتم
مباراتهم السره لذلك العدد يرتفع حقيقه
الامر لذلك الصدمه الاولى كانت كبيره جدا
كبيره على امكانيات الجميع نحن نتحدث عن
مفقودين اكثر من الفين مفقود لان الامر لم
يتعلق فقط في البحث
بالمناطق الكبرى التي جرى البحث فيها هناك
مناطق لم تصلها فرق الالقاس كان مشاركه
كبيره ايضا من طرف الانقاذ التي تتابع لهي
التحرير الشام وعملت بجديه مدنيين شاركوا
بالياتهم مع فرق الدفاع المدني التي عملت
بشكل بطولي اي ان مجموعات عده عملات في
تلك المنطقه لكن بالنهايه كان حجم الزلزال
اكبر من امكانياتها بكثير هذا بالنسبه
لهذه البقعه الجغرافيه ايضا مناطق النظام
التي اصابها الزلزال من حلب ومرورا بريف
حلب الشرقي وصولا اللاذقيه الى قرى في
القدموس وايضا جبله التي كان لها نصيب
الاكبر وريف حماه هناك مناطق متناشره كل
يوم يعني نسمع ونوسف ونتاكد من وجود دقائق
جدد داخل التراب السوري
تفضل طيب استاذ رامي عندما نقول مفقودين
فقط لنفهم المشاهدين عندما نقول مفقودين
هل هم يعني ما زالوا تحت الركام يعني في
عداد القتلى ام لا يعني مصيرهم يبقى
مجهولا والبت في هذا المصير صعب الى وقت
الى وقت نعم لذلك نحن لم نرفع الاحصائيه
في عداد الالفي المفقود الذين يعني تاكدنا
من وجود هذا العدد يعني ننتظر ونبحث
وعندما ينتهي الامر ويقول لنا بانه تم
البحث على سبيل المثال الجنديرس يعني هل
معقول في اربعه ايام بحثنا في 14 مبنى
وكان هناك اكثر من 84 مبنى مهدم بحثنا في
المباني الاخرى جنديرس عمليه الانقاص فيها
موجوده ولكن قليله هناك الكثير من الذين
لا نعلم اذا ما كانوا بالفعل تحت الانقاذ
ام قتلوا ودفنوا اما يعني في النقاط
الطبيه وجرى انتقاله من النقاط الطبيه
واورث الامر يحتاج الى يعني ايام وليس
ساعات يعني قد يحتاج الى اساس ايضا يتبين
ان جميع المفقودين فارق الحياه ام لا يسار
يعني يا رب
استاذ رامي بالنسبه الى العائلات عشرات او
مئات العائلات
المتكدسه في معبر باب الهوى والعائلات
السوريه ويريدون العبور يعني من
الجانب التركي من المعبر الى الاراضي
السوريه اولا هل من معلومات عن وضع هذه
العائلات وهي تريد ان ادخل الى المناطق
السوريه لماذا وهل سمح لها بالعوده
الى اين ستذهب محلنا في حال عادت نعم تعود
الى الاراضي السوريه لكن الى اين ستذهب هل
هناك بالفعل اماكن للعيش في ظل هذه
الاوضاع الكارثيه في تلك المناطق نحن
نشاهد معبر باب الهوى ولكن المعبر باب
السلام
الراعي والمعامر على الحدود مع تركيا في
مناطق ما تعرف بالحكومه المؤكده ايضا يوجد
فيها تكدس ولكن في تلك المنطقه كون ان
العلاقه قويه جدا مع الحكومه التركيه لا
يتحدثون عن هذا الامر ويقولون بانهم
عائدون للزياره يعني
من يعود الى الزياره في هذا في ظل هذه
الماسات الموجوده
الجسد السوريين تعود من الاراضي التركيه
وتدخل من معبر باب الهواء ومهابر يعني
نتحدث ونشاهدها باستمرار التكتم شديد في
بعض السلامه وبعض الراعي
في بريطانيا مدير المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان رامي عبد الرحمن شكرا جزيلا لك
استاذ رامي على هذه المتابعه
هذا وخلف زلزال تركيا وسوريا الكثير من
القصص الماساويه لاشخاص فقدوا اقاربهم
وذويهم من بينهم سيده مسنه في ريف ادلب
توفي خمسه من احفادها كما تعرض بنوها
لاصابات بليغه
راهم كل امراه اولاده
كلمات قليله قد لا تختزل حجب معاناه هذه
السيده التي وجدت نفسها بين ليله وضحاها
وحيده بعدما خسرت من كانوا يسندون ظهرها
ويعينونها على عاديات الزمان
لحظه لم تتجاوز الدقيقه كانت كافيه لتجعل
هذه السيده تعيش ماساه حقيقيه اصابه
ابنيها ووفاه احفادها حتى منزلها لم يتبقى
منه سوى الانقاض التي جلست تبكي عليها
حسره وحزنا على قساوه المقاله اولادي
مستاجرين
وانا مستاجر
ما شفت
مقعدوني قالوا لي البنايه
[ضحك]
اذا له ذهب بخمسه من احفادها وادى الى
اصابات بليغه بابها
واحد مكسور ظهره ووعد مكسوره رقبته
[موسيقى]
دار اولادي
السيده ترفض مغادره المكان فاين لها ان
تذهب ومن عاشت لاجلهم لسنوات التهمهم
الزلزال والدمار بدي اتفرج ادوري
عشان اشوف دوري قبل ما يشيلوه كل امنيتها
الان ايجاد جفاميل المفقودين تحت الانقاد
والقاء نظره وداع اخيرا لن تواسيها حجم
الماساه وسام ذهبي العربيه
وفي ظل الدمار الكبيره الذي لحق بالمباني
والمنازل في مدينه حلب السوريه يعاني
الناجون من البرد القارس وانخفاض درجات
الحراره ما دفع بعض المتطوعين الى اطلاق
حمله تبرع بالملابس للناجين لاسيما
الاطفال منهم السياره
جاكيت يا جماعه جاكيت
في حدا اكل بوت بوت ولادي
بنطلون ولادي معنا اعطوني
يا جماعه
هذا وما تزال بلده جنديرس في عفرين شمال
غرب سوريا تعاني من اثار الزلزال المدمر
الذي حل بها قبل عشره ايام ان جون من
اهالي البلده يحاولون ادراك حجم الكارثه
التي حلت بهم ويطالبون باغاثتهم وتقديم
المساعده العاجله لهم
ينتظر وحيدا واستحاله من الصدمه والالم
انه من جنديرس البلده المنكوبه اثر
الزلزال المدمر
الدمار في كل مكان وناجون يتجرعون الام
فقدان عائلاتهم واقاربهم يحاولون استيعاب
حجم الخسائر الكبيره التي حلت بهم نحن
نبرك تحت هيك ما في اي مشكله بس اطفال
نساء
المصاب اللي طالعناه من تحت التراب يعني
ردود كذا هلق نزلت انا اولادي على المشفى
جسمه كله ازرق يعني اكثر من 270 بناء
انهدموا على الارض تماما اكثر من الف بناء
خارج كان يعني لا يصلح للسكن انا 3900
عائله لا تملك اي ماوى
في حقول بالقرب من المباني المدمره نصبت
بعض الخيام لايواء المنكوبين وقسم اخر
افترش ارضيه صاله رياضيه بانتظار اي
مساعدات قد تخفف من معاناتهم
الحمد لله
وضعنا كتير تعبان
جنديرس هي المنطقه الاكثر كارثيه وتضررا
من الزلزال وفق التقارير وهو ما تعكسه
شكاوى ونداءات سكانها الذين يطالبون
بمساعدات عاجله تساعدهم على الصمود امام
الكارثه التي حلت بهم
وين المساعدات ملوك الشيخ العربيه
الصحفي مسلم السيد عيسى استاذ مسلم اهلا
وسهلا بك كيف يبدو لك المشهد في هذه
الاوقات خصوصا عمليات الانقاذ والاغاثه
وهل تصل المساعدات الى مستحقيها وفق
متابعتي
نعم في الحقيقه سابدا بالسياق المتعلق
بمرحله رفع الانقاذ والبحث عن جثه
المفقودين لا تزال عمليات هذه البحث عن
الجثث المفقودين بعد ان اشار الدفاع
المدني انه لا وجود لاحياء في هذه المناطق
التي تدمرت بشكل كامل من المتوقع ان تستمر
هذه العمليه ربما عشره ايام 15 يوم بحسب
التقديرات الاوليه لان الامكانيات او
الدفاع المدني يتعامل مع الامكانيات
المحليه المتواجده بين يديه بعد عدم وجود
اي معدات او دعم من خارج الحدود لهذه او
لفرق الدفاع والانقاذ على الشق الاخر
بشق الانسان بشكل اساسي يعني هناك الاف
العوائل لا تزال حتى هذه اللحظه بحاجه الى
دعم ومساعدات انسانيه اليوم رايت هنا وصلت
بعض العائلات الى مدينه ادلب يعني الوضع
حقيقه كارثي لا يمكن للكلمات ان تصب خصوصا
وضع الاطفال والنساء وكبار السن الذين
يتوافدون الى المناطق الجنوبيه من محافظه
ادلب بحثا عن بيوت منازل مراكز لواء
جماعيه وغيرها المساعدات التي دخلت
عبر ثلاث معابر حدوديه وهي معبر باب الهوى
هو باب السلامه وايضا معبر الحمام باقه
عددها 115 شاحنه توزعت بين المؤسسات
المحليه التركيه وايضا المؤسسات السعوديه
والمؤسسات القطريه والكويتيه والمساعدات
الامميه بشكل خاص يبدو ان الامم المتحده
بدات او اخذت قرار فعلي يعني للضخ وادخال
المزيد من الشاحنات عبر الحدود المخصصه
لكارثه الزلزال لكن هذه الشاحنات مجموعها
وبحسب المنظمات المحليه قالت انها لا تسد
الا 10% باقصى تقدير وبافضل حال من
الاحتياجات الانسانيه
للسكان والمناطق والمناطق التي تضررت بشكل
كبير بدء توزيع المساعدات بفعل اساس بشكل
اساسي
مسلم بدي اسالك فقط يعني لانه في كثير من
المعلومات المتضاربه حول موضوع حركه توزيع
المساعدات انه بعض فصائل المعارضه قالت
انها لن تستقبل اي مساعدات تاتي من مناطق
سيطره الحكومه وهذا قيل انه عرقل وصول
وتسليم المساعدات هل فعلا ما زالت بعض
الفصائل ترفض ذلك والى اي مدى هذا يؤثر
على تدفق المساعدات في مناطق سيطره
المعارضه
يعني هناك حقيقه هذا الملف يشوبه الكثير
من التعقيد بسبب الحواجز التي تفصل بين
مناطق المعارضه ومناطق النظام لا يمكن
يعني ان نقول ان هناك احد يعرقل لان
المساعدات الامميه يعني قبل الزلزال بثلاث
ايام دخلت قافله للامم المتحده عبر خطوط
التماس بين مناطق النظام والمعارضه لكن
يبدو ان هناك الكثير من التعقيدات على ارض
الواقع لان عبور هذه الشاحنات يحتاج الى
التنسيق مع عشرات الجهات
والتسهيل وصولها لكن بالمقابل الاطراء
يعني الاطراف وكما شاهدت هنا انا اتحدث عن
مناطق المعارضه هي مفتوحه لعبور المساعدات
خاصه التي قدم من
مجلس الامن او موافقه مجلس الامن
والمساعدات الاماميه
مكونه من خمسه عشر شاحنه ثلاث ايام من هذه
الكارثه لكن هناك توضيح مهم ان المساعدات
المساعدات التي تاتي عبر الحدود
هي اسهل لوجستيه وسهله وسريعه الوصول
للمستفيدين لان مساعدات التي تقدم عبر
الحدود والمعابر الحدوديه لا يتوقف لا
يمكن ايقافها بهذا القدر من ادلب الصحفي
مسلم السيد عيسى شكرا على هذه المتابعه
في تركيا ومع تواصل عمليات انقاذ
المتضررين من الزلزال المدمر اظهر مقطع
فيديو تم تداوله عبر منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي عمليه انقاذ امراه تبلغ من
العمر 42 عاما في قهرمان مرعش التركيه بعد
222 ساعه على الزلزال
وقد اظهر مقطع فيديو تم تداوله ايضا عبر
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي عمليه انقاذ سيده
وطفليها من تحت انقاذ مبنى في انطقيا
التركيه بعد
228 ساعه من الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب
البلاد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وزير الداخليه التركيه سليمان الصويلو اكد
انه لا يزال هناك احياء يتم اخراجهم من
تحت الانقاب تزامنا مع تسجيل هزه جديده
بقوه 4.7 درجات على مقياس ريختر ضربت
قهرمان مرعش مشيرا الى مضاعفه عدد القوى
الامنيه في المناطق المنكوبه ثلاث مرات
ولافتا الى ان هناك احياء لا يزالون تحت
الانقاض ويجري اخراجهم باسرع وقت ممكن
سؤال اعلن ايضا عن هدم خمسين بالمئه من
المباني المتضرره خلال ايام قليله بسبب
عدم صلاحيتها مضيفنا ان الحياه ستعود
لطبيعتها في المناطق المنكوبه من الزلزال
خلال ايام
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بك من جديد جديد مشهد عمليات
الاغاثه وهل ما زالت عمليات الانقاذ
مستمره ام لا يعني انتهت بشكل او باخر نحن
في اليوم العاشر على الزلزال الكلمه لك
عمار تفضل
ساجيبك طالب ولكن سريعا يعني تصديقا لما
جاء في مقدمه النشره الان التي قراتها نعم
هذه عمليات هدم مثلا تجري الان لمبنى مدمر
وايل للسقوط يعني تقوم هذه الاليات بهدمه
والان يعني منذ دقائق بدات فيه على ايه
حال نحن لا زلنا نجول في مناطق انطاكيا
وفي
المتواحي السكنيه المنكوبه والمدمره
عمليات الانقاذ مستمره طالب ولكن يعني
بشكل مختلف هذه الملابس العزل التي تظهر
من امامك هي التي بدات ترتديها فرق
الانقاذ مؤخرا لان خشيه الامراض والاوبئه
وانتشارها هنالك طبعا بدات تختفي عمليات
البحث عن الناجين بصراحه رغم ان طبعا انا
سمعت الخبر عن السيده وطفليها وهذا صحيح
ولكن بنسبه قليله جدا يعني تكون هنالك
عمليات بحث عن ناجين تحت الانقاض ولكن
المشكله الاكبر اطالب الان ان العمليات بد
يعني
تزداد بوتيره مختلفه وكما قلت لك بملابس
العزل للبحث عن تحت الانقاظ عن الجثانين
ومثلا هذا المبنى الذي تشاهده يعني فيه
طبعا اسر لا تزال تحت الانقاظ حتى هذه
اللحظه هذا الكيس الاسود الذي يظهر في
الشاشه لطفله عمرها 25 يوم اخرجت من تحت
انقاذ هذا المبنى وضعت هنا جاء من يعني
يتجمهرون
والاسر الواقفه هنا منذ ايام تعرفوا اليها
كانت هنالك صعوبه صوروها وارسلوها الى
اشخاص لعائلات سوريه وبالفعل في نهايه
الامر تعرفت اليها عائله وتبين انها تخص
عائله سوريه ولكن هنالك من لا يزال ينتظر
المزيد من الجثث والضحايا هذه طبعا
الاكياس السوداء ايضا طالب
هذه جثث ايضا خرجت لرجل وامراه كما يحدثني
شخص هنا خرجت من تحت الانقاض يتم التعرف
اليها بمجرد ان تخرض تخرج الجثه ياتي
الناس هنا من ينتظر ويتعرف على هذه الجثث
اسمح لي سريعا طالب انا اتحدث الى شخص
الذي تخصه جثه هذه الطفله ولديه المزيد
تحياتي اولا نتعرف عليك انا اسمي ضياء من
حلب ساكن باورفه اولا يسلم راسكم تعازينا
الحاره هذه الطفله بنت اختك
بنت اخوك عفوا والناس اجت تعرفت عليها
وبعدين انت تعرفت عليها وهي تخصك وسيسار
الى دفنها كم شخص لا يزال تحت الانقاذ
عندك من هذا الطفله هاي الساعه 6 اشخاص
هذا المبنى بهذا المبنى صلي على عشره ايام
هون انا عم بستنى
يعني ما المغرب ما سكروا وطفوا باذن الله
اليوم بخلصوهم يعني صار لنا عشره ايام هون
انا بنام بالشارع هون
عندي كمان اخوي بالطرف الثاني طالع انا
بعد 30 ساعه هذا هو بالمشفى اضنه الله
يجزيه الخيرة
بس مرته
عندي ابن اختي كمان بالطرف الثاني هو
ومرته واولاده تحت الانقاص بنخت طلع هو
موجود هون بيناتنا بعد اربعه ايام ومرته
كانت
ايديها رايحات قطع ايديها وتوفت ما تحملت
واولاده 2 ماتوا ليش قطعوا ايديها ما فهمت
ايديها جايات شو اسمه تحت عامود جسر طروا
لباتري اليدين اضطروا
ايديها توفت الحمد لله
رحمها الله الحمد لله
عمرها 25 يوم 25 يوم صحيح
بغير محلات رحت دورت المشافي هون والجسس
اكثر من 500 جثه بمشفى الدوله الجديد
دورتم اطفال
خمس اطفال خمس اطفال كم اعمارهم الكبير
عمره 10 سنين والباقي اربع بنات ثمانيه
سنين ست سنين
وثلاثه سنين تقريبا هي اربع سنين وانا
عيلتي عايفه باورفه بصلي هون عشر ايام
يعني انت غير هذه الطفله لديك خمس اطفال
للسجون مع الطفل مع الطفله خمس اطفال مع
الطفله هذه
وانا لله وانا اليه راجعون انا لله وانا
اليه راجعون انا اشكرك واعزيك وان شاء
الله انه يعني هذا الحال يعني يزول الهم
ان شاء الله ويعني ان شاء الله يهدا بالك
وتعود الى بيتك انت لك عشر ايام الان في
الشارع عشر ايام بالشارع رحت بس نهار واحد
رحت على اورفا بدلت اغراضي امبارح بالليل
واليوم الصبح انا كنت هون
اي ساعه تتوقف عمليات اي ساعه تتوقف
عمليات الانقاذ
صار يشتغلوا مزبوط ان شاء الله تستمر هون
هلا عم يشتغلوا للساعه 6:00 امبارح الساعه
6:00 وقفوا ان شاء الله ان شاء الله تستمر
وتكون وتستمر وتنتهي هذه الازمه طالب يعني
يا عمار انا انا بس اسف يعني للمقاطعه
امام هول ما اشاهده وانت تشاهده يعني هذه
الجثث حتى لاطفال يحضرني بيت شعر لحافظ
ابراهيم يعني يقول نبهاني ان كنتما
تعلماني ما دهى الكون ايها الفرقدان للاسف
على كل منها طائر مفرد العربيه عمار
الهندي شكرا جزيلا لك عمار على كل هذه
المتابعه
تواصل دخول شاحنات المساعدات عبر معبر باب
الهوى الى شمال غرب سوريا وقد دخلت اليوم
22 شاحنه من المساعدات الامميه ليصل العدد
الاجمالي الى 106 شاحنات وقد رصدت كاميرا
العربيه جانبا من حركه مرور بعض المساعدات
[موسيقى]
من معبر باب الهواء الحدودي بين سوريا
وتركيا انضم اليها الصحفي محمد الاشقر
محمد اهلا وسهلا بك كيف هي حركه العبور من
والى معبر باب الهوى وابرز المشاهدات التي
سجلتها اليوم
نعم يعني في الحقيقه دعني ابدا الحديث عن
دخول السوريين الناجين من المناطق التي
تضررت بالزلزال في تركيا يعني حيث وصل
عددهم الى حد هذه اللحظه الى ما يقارب ال
670 شخص من مختلف الاعمار من الاطفال
والنساء والرجال طبعا يستمر دخول الوافدين
حتى هذه
يتم نقلهم من معبر باب الهوى باتجاه مدينه
سرمدا كمرحله اوليه ومن ثم يذهبون الى
اقاربهم في عموم مناطق ريف ادلب طبعا ان
تحدثنا قليلا عن المساعدات الانسانيه التي
تدخل عن طريق معبر باب الهوى فالى حد هذه
اللحظه دخلت
106 شاحنات
محمله بالمساعدات الانسانيه المقدمه من
الامم المتحده عبر هذا المعبر اليوم دخلت
اخر القافلات حتى هذه اللحظه حيث سجل دخول
شاحنه مساعدات امميه تم دخولها عبر معبر
باب الهوى وتسليمها بشكل مباشر للمنظمات
الشريكه للامم المتحده التي وضعت خطط
توزيعها وايصالها للمتضررين من هذا
الزلزال هناك العديد من الشاحنات ايضا
التابعه لمختلف الجمعيات الانسانيه
والمنظمات
المحليه والدوليه التي دخلت عن طريق هذا
المعبر اليوم طبعا الى حد هذه اللحظه
يستمر دخول الشاحنات طبعا لمحترف فقط
للمقاطعه اريد فقط
في مناطق سيطره المعارضه في موضوع توزيع
المساعدات هل فعلا يعني عمليه توزيع
المساعدات والمواد الاغاثيه تتم بشكل سلس
ومنظم ام لا في بعض الاحيان هنالك فوضى
نعم
نعم يعني لا لا يعني لا يمكننا ان نقول ان
عمليات التوزيع تتم جميعها بشكل ثلاث هناك
بعض حالات الفوضى التي تتم في بعض المناطق
وذلك بسبب
العدد الكبير
للمتضررين وعدم قدره يعني الفرق والمنظمات
الموجوده حاليا في شمال غرب سوريا على
استيعاب هذا العدد الهائل طبعا يتم توجه
المنظمات والفرق المسؤوله عن ايصال هذه
المساعدات بالدرجه الاولى الى القرى
والبلدات والمدن المتضرره من هذا الزلزال
لايصال المساعدات للمتضررين كما يتوجهون
بشكل مباشر الى مراكز الايواء هنا دعني
اتحدث عن نقطه مهمه هناك العديد من
الناجين المتضررين لجاوا الى منازل
اقربائهم في عموم مناطق شمال غرب سوريا
التي تمتد من ريف اللاذقيه الى مدينه ج
طيب في ريف حلب
يصعب على الفرق والمنظمات الوصول الى
هؤلاء المتضررين في الوقت الحالي ولكن
بحسب
الذين التقيناهم قالوا ان الايام المقبله
ستشهد اكثر عملا محمد محمد شكرا جزيلا لك
على هذه المتابعه سنكون معك في نشرات
لاحقه لمزيد من المعلومات من معبر باب
الهوى
نشاط الخامسه مستمره في ايضا
داعش يعدم اثني عشر شخصا بينهم امراه في
باديه تدمر في سوريا
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنا المرصد السوري
لحقوق الانسان ان تنظيم داعش اعدم 12 شخصا
بينهم امراه فيما لا يزال مصيره ثلاثه
وستين اخرين مجهولا وقال المرصد انه جرى
اختطافهم اثناء جمع الكما في باديه تدمر
ومضى على اختطافهم نحو خمسه ايام ولفت
المرصد الى ان ذلك ياتي في ظل استغلال
خلايا التنظيم انشغال المجتمع الدولي
والعالم بكارثه الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب
سوريا وتركيا
[موسيقى]
اعلن امين وعام حلف الناتو عن تعهدات
جديده من دول الحلف لاوكرانيا تشمل تقديم
اسلحه ثقيله ياتي ذلك في وقت اعلن فيه
وزير الدفاع البريطاني عن اجراء تدريبات
عسكريه لجنود اوكرانيين يقاتلون بطريقه
اكثر غربيه ويستخدمون ذخيره اقل من
الطريقه السوفيتيه التقليديه في القتال
واضاف ولص ان التدريبات تاتي بهدفي تعويد
الاوكرانيين على عدم استخدام الذخيره
بكميات كبيره بل بطريقه مثمره ودقيقه
للغايه لتحقيق نتائج ملموسه حسب تعبيري
وحول ارسال طائرات لاوكرانيا اوضح ان
الامر يتطلب تدريبا طويلا للطيارين وفرق
دعم كبيره لكن يمكن توريد اسلحه مثل
الصواريخ المضاده للطائرات
وفي ظل هذه التطورات قال وزير الخارجيه
الروسي ان الولايات المتحده والناتو رفضاء
محاولات بلاده لخفض التوتر مع اوكرانيا
بشكل وصفه بانه متغطرس واضاف لابروب امام
البرلمان ان نهج الغرب لتحويل اوكرانيا
الى ساحه معاديه لروسيا وصل الى نقطه
اللاعوده حاليا معتبرا ان محاولات عزل
بلاده بائت بالفشل ومشيرا الى ان السياسه
الخارجيه لبلاده ستركز على انهاء هيمنه
الغرب
وفي التطورات الميدانيه قال دينيس بوشلين
القائم باعمال الرئاسه في جمهوريه دانيتش
المعترف بها من جانب روسيا قال ان الجيش
الاوكراني لن يتخلى عن ضخمه بسهوله وبدون
قتال مضيفا ان القتال العنيف يدور في
الجزء الجنوبي الشرقي من مدينه وان هناك
نجاحات وتقدم للجيش الروسي في مقاطعه مع
تقدم في منطقه ليمن كومبيانس والتي شهدت
عوده القوات الروسيه اليها عقب الانسحاب
منها في وقت سابق
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه كانت قد اعلنت في
بيان نشرته اليوم عن تراجع القوات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه لمسافه ثلاثه
كيلومترات في منطقه لوغانس مشيره الى ان
خط الدفاع الثاني وهو الاكثر تحصينا
للاوكرانيين لم يستطع صد الهجوم الروسي
الدفاع الروسيه اشارت ايضا الى ان
الاوكرانيين هربوا من مواقعهم تاركين
ممتلكات عسكريه
وجثث القتلى بالاضافه الى الالغام التي
غطت بها القوات الاوكرانيه المنطقه اثناء
تراجعيه
وصلت كاميرا العربيه الى الخط الحدودي
الفاصل بين بيلاروسيا واوكرانيا وتحديدا
معبر ديفين سماري الذي يشهد اغلاقا تاما
منذ ثلاث سنوات وتصعيدا متزايدا خلال عام
الحرب الدائره في الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وتتحدث التقارير عن استعداد اطراف النزاع
الاوكراني بشكل كبير لاي مواجهات محتمله
وسط توقعات باستخدام موسكو الاراضي
البيلاروسيه للدخول من الشمال الاوكرانيه
من الحدود البيلاروسيه الاوكرانيه ينضم
الي مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد عبد
الجواد اهلا وسهلا بك جديد المشهد من عندك
خصوصا وان الاعلام الغربي ما زال يضج
بالتقارير عن قرب شن هجوم روسي واسع
النطاق وسيكون ليلاروسيا دور في
مساء الخير طالب نعم بالفعل نحن لا نقف في
اقصى الغرب البيلاروسي هو معبر
الواصل بين الاراضي البيلاروسيه من جهه
والاراضي الاوكرانيه طبعا هذا المعبر طالب
مقفل منذ نحو ثلاث سنوات طبعا بداه
الازمه الاوكرانيه والصراع موسكو مع الغرب
الطينه بيلا بهذا الوضع المنطقه مغلقه
بشكل كامل طالب طبعا لا يمكنني الحديث ان
الوضع هادئ بالرغم من اننا لم نشاهد
العنصر العسكري في المنطقه من ان القوات
الاوكرانيه او القوات البيلاروسيه الان
يعني
نوعا ما بعناصر للجيش
طبعا في هذه النقطه التي نقف فيها الان
هناك تواجد عسكري بيلاروسيا نوعا ما بشكل
كبير المعدات طبعا موجوده في هذا المكان
نلاحظ طالب طبعا وجود يعني عناصر من قوات
الحرس الخاص التابع للقوات البيلاروسيه هي
عناصر غير موجوده عاده على الحدود
الحدود الفاصل بين الاراضي البيلاروسيه
والاوكرانيا لكن الوضع الراهن والتصعيد
الكبير بين مينسك وموسكو من جهه وبينكيه
وحلفائها من جهه اخرى فرض هذا الوضع هناك
طبعا طالب بعض القوات على ما يبدو انها
تستعد لاجراء تدريبات نوعا ما في خلال هذه
الفتره كما نلاحظ طبعا هي تحمل اسلحه
حديثه ولديها يعني كما نلاحظ بدلات عسكريه
وبالذات يعني هي تعمل على كما نلاحظ يعني
اني اسمح لنا المشهد نلاحظ بعض الاسلحه
يتم طبعا استخدام بندقيه
كلاشنكوف كما الاحظ طبعا من هذا الموضوع
لكن طالب على العموم الوضع على الحدود
البيلاروسيه الاوكرانيه هو قلق نوعا ما هي
مغلقه بشكل كامل عدد المعابر بين الدولتين
يصل الى اثنين
معبرا كلها مغلقه طالب ان كانت للقطارات
وان كانت للحافلات وان كانت للسيارات
وللناس جميعها مغلقه بشكل كامل عبد الجواد
انا كنت اريد ان اكمل هذا النقاش ولكن
الصوره والصوت يتقطعان من المصدر شكرا
جزيلا لك على كلنا على كل هذه المعلومات
عبد الجواد الرشود من الحدود الاوكرانيه
البيلاروسيه
مفوضيه الاوروبيه
لحزمه عاشره من العقوبات ضد روسيا تشمل
حظر التجاره وفرض ضوابط على صادرات
التكنولوجيا الروسيه بقيمه 11 مليار يورو
اعلنت ايضا عن شموليه العقوبات الاوروبيه
الجديده ضد روسيا لتصدير مكونات تصنيع
المسيرات كما اضافت ان المفوضيه تدرس فرض
عقوبات جديده ضد ايران بسبب دورها في
الحرب في اوكرانيا
التي تصنع المسيرات وقد بحثنا يوم امس في
اجتماع حلف الناتو ادله قاطعه على تزويد
ايران لروسيا بالمسيرات
الى بروكسل الان ينضم الي لمزيد من
المتابعه حول هذه العقوبات مراسل العربي
نور الدين الفريد نور عن اي عقوبات جديده
نتحدث الان والى اي ماذا سيكون هنالك
توافق اوروبي او اجماع اوروبي على هذه
الحزمه الجديده ام لا ثم خلافات تبرز منذ
الان
في هذه المرحله طالب
الاقتراح الذي قدمته ارسل بندلين وجزير
خاصه لان الامر يعود الى ادارته اداره
العلاقات الخارجيه يبحث على مستوى
المندوبين الدائمين للدول الاعضاء 27 على
ان يتم التوصل ربما هذا المساء من هنا الى
الجمعه الى اتفاق سياسي ويعرض هذا الاتفاق
على وزراء الخارجيه يوم الاثنين المصادقه
عليه فيما يتعلق بهذه النقطه بالذات وهي
ادانه ايران
واتخاذ عقوبات ضد المؤسسات والمسؤولين
الايرانيين الذين يرعون عمليات تصدير
الاسلحه وخاصه المسيرات الى الى روسيا هذه
النقطه لا تثير اي خلاف بين الدول
الاوروبيه وبالتالي متوقع ان يكون اجماع
حول هذه المساله مساله ادراج سبع كيانات
ايرانيه تصنع مسيره شاهد قالت عنها ارسنال
انها تستخدم في الاعتداء على اوكرانيا
وتدمير بناها المدنيه
التحتيه قال جوزيف الذي شارك في اجتماعات
حلف شمال الاطلسي امس ان الحلفه بحث ادله
قاطعه عن وجودها المسيرات واستخدامها في
اوكرانيا كيف يتم ذلك كانت تحدثت في
مناسبه سابقه عن ان الاوكرانيين يجمعون
حطام هذه الطائرات يسلمونها الى دول
الشريكه بمعنى الى الدول الاوروبيه
لبحثها عندما يتم رصد بعض الشركات في هذه
القطعه المدمره وفي الشظائف يتم تحديد
ربما بعض المكونات الصناعيه التي تتزودها
ايران من دول غربيه فان او من شركات
الغربيه فان هذه الشركات الشركه الايرانيه
وكذلك الشركات الغربيه
عليها طيب نحن نتحدث الان عن مقترحات
لحزمه عاشره لحظر التجاره كامله من روسيا
الضوابط على صادرات التكنولوجيا الروسيه
بقيمه 11 مليار يورو طيب السؤال هنا هل
الكل متفق على ذلك يعني ماذا عن موقف
هنغاريا موقف صربيا وغيرها من الدول
الاوروبيه التي موقفها الى حد ما مهاد
لموسكو
نعم فعلا على مداء الاشهر للسنه الاولى من
هذه الحرب كانت اوكرانيا دائما تجر خطاها
او تكون الاخيره التي تصادق وتوافقوا على
هاته العقوبات لا لم يعني لم تنفرد المجر
باي تسويت في اي مناسبه ضد حزم من الحزن
حزمه العقوبات التي تتخذ
بقاعده اجماع الدول الاعضاء نعم هناك موقف
سياسي معلن رايناه حتى في خلال لقاء القمه
القمه الاوروبيه الاسبوع الماضي والرئيس
زيلينسكي راينا
المسافحه من دون ابتسامه بينما كان الجميع
يصفق لي
الرئيس او رئيس الوزراء اوربا فيكتور
اوربان رئيس الوزراء المجري تحفظ عن
التصفيق عندما دخل القاعه او في صوره
جماعيه نعم هذا الموقف موجود يتوقع ان
تعلن
موقفها مره اخرى لكن لن ربما يخاطب ان
يجازف القول انها لن تعترض او لن تستخدم
الفيتو ضد هذه العاشره من العقوبات ضد
روسيا والتي ستصدر ربما في بدايه الاسبوع
المقبل او فجره
ذكرى الاولى لهذه الحرب حرب اوكرانيا من
بروكسل مراسل العربي نور الدين شكرا جزيلا
لك نور على كل هذه المتابعه
شدد وزير الدفاع العراقي ثابت العباسي في
تصريحات خاصه للعربيه على رفض كل اشكال
التعدي على سياده العراق مشيرا الى ان
الحكومه العراقيه ستعمل على توفير
الامكانيات والسلاح اللازم للحفاظ على
سياده البلاد السياده خط احمر ولا يمكن
السماح ولا التهاون في هذا الموضوع الرجال
موجودين
معاليه في الحفاظ على السياده لكن يحتاجون
لادوات والى
امور تسانده في هذا الموضوع هذا المجال
تكاد تكون هذه الحكومه الحكومه
لا اقول الوحيد بل
من الحكومات التي ذاقت كافه القوى
السياسيه المنضويه في تشكيلات الحكومه
وعود كامله لدوله رئيس الوزراء والوزاره
الدفاع بتوفير الفرص الكامله
للتسليح لغرض الحفاظ على السياده ولغرض
تعزيز القدرات العسكريه لوزاره الدفاع
الشطرسه مستمره فيها ايضا
عن اختيار شخص مناسب لاداره تويتر بحلول
نهايه العام
اهلا بكم من جديد قالت كوريا الجنوبيه ان
ازمه الغذاء في كوريا الشماليه تفاقمت في
الفتره الاخيره حيث ذكرت وسائل الاعلام
محليه ان كوريا الشماليه خفضت الحصص
الغذائيه لجنودها لاول مره منذ اكثر من
عقدين
في كوريا الشماليه الوضع الغذائي يتدهور
كوريا الجنوبيه كشفت عن ازمه غذاء في
كوريا الشماليه الازمه هي الاولى منذ اكثر
من عقدين وسائل اعلام في كوريا الجنوبيه
قالت بان كوريا الشماليه خفضت الحصص
الغذائيه لجنودها كما اقرت فعليا بنقص
خطير في الغذاء اجتماع مرتقب للحزب الحاكم
في كوريا الشماليه لمعالجه الوضع وبحث
انشاء استراتيجيه تهدف لدعم قطاع الزراعه
كوريا الشماليه عانت على مدى العقود
الاخيره من ازمه غذاء وصلت لدرجه المجاعه
في التسعينات
كانت نتيجه للكوارث الطبيعيه التي دمرت
المحاصيل الزراعيه القطاع الزراعي فشل في
تحقيق الاهداف المتعلقه بالحبوب بسبب
الاعاصير المداريه العمل الماضي توفر
الغذاء في كوريا الشماليه انخفض الى ما
دون الحد الادنى فيما يتعلق باحتياجات
الانسان
اعلن ايلون ماسك الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه
تويتر انه سيعين شخصا مناسبا لاداره تويتر
بحلول نهايه العام الحالي لتصبح في وضع
مستقر ولها خارطه طريق واضحه
اعتقد انني بحاجه الى تحقيق الاستقرار في
تويتر والتاكد من ان موقف المنصه الماليه
صحيح ولها خريطه طريق واضحه ربما بحلول
نهايه العام سيكون هناك شخص مناسب يدير
الشركه التي يجب ان تصبح في وضع مستقر هذا
العام
الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه تويتر قال ايضا ان
الذكاء الاصطناعي سيكون امرا مقلقا على
المدى القريب خاصه وان العالم لا يولي
اهتماما كبيرا لدرجات امان الذكاء
الاصطناعي والاشراف الرقابي عليه
من الصعب التوقع بشان التطور التكنولوجي
بشكل دقيق خلال عشره اعوام بسبب التطورات
المتسارعه هناك تحول اتجاه الطاقه
المستدامه مع طاقه الرياح والبطاريات
والشمس والسيارات الكهربائيه ايضا القاعده
الصناعيه الاقتصادات الوقود الاحفوري
اعتقد ان امكانيه استبدال السيارات
القديمه باخرى تعمل بالطاقه الكهربائيه قد
يستغرق 20 عاما والامر بشكل عام ربما
يحتاج من 30 الى 40 عاما على المدى القريب
الذكاء الاصطناعي سيكون امرا مقلقا خاصه
وان العلم لاهتماما كبيرا بدرجات امان
الذكاء الاصطناعي والاشراف الرقابي عليه
شكرا لمحمد نشره الخامسه انتهت اطيب
التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]